ん
[音楽]
me
皆さんこんにちは総合人間科学部社会学科
3年の当たられた書と申します
皆様ほとんどが私のかを初めて拝見される
と思いますが今回愛育
といいますかこの様のお陰でオンデマンド
で開催との運びになりまして皆様のこいつ
の話睡眠導入剤だなぁなんてうとうとし
てらっしゃるかを見なくて済むということ
だけが不幸中の幸いとでも申しましょうか
まぁまぁそんな話は置いといてですね今回
私が皆様とお話しさせていただくテーマは
多様性という言葉遊びとその本質について
です今日私は私なりの角度からの多様性の
本質に迫るアイディアを2つご用意させて
いただきましてこの場で紹介させて
いただきます
そして今回この場が皆様が少しでも多様性
に近づきそして興味を持っていただく
チャンスとなれば嬉しいと思っております
さてここでいきなりクイズです私は一体何
しに見えるでしょうか
もしかしたら日本語を喋れるからまあ当然
日本人でしょ思われる方もいらっしゃるか
もしれませんし
見た目はアジアだけど一アジア家もしくは
を何人でもいいからちょっと先に話を進め
てくれなんて思っていらっしゃる方もいる
かもしれません
実は答えはそんなにいい大事ではなくて
ですね私のアイデンティティなので一応
大事ではあるんですが今回のこの質問の
意図は実は質問の方にあります
今回色々な僕をですね皆さん頭の中で想像
されたと思うんですが先に答えから言って
しまうと私はイギリス生まれの日中ア二メ
中国育ち国籍は日本国籍しか持っており
ません
おそらく皆様の中でこれを一発で当てれた
方をいないんじゃないかなと思うんですが
もしあてる方がいらっしゃったら今すぐ島
cia か fbi かを好きに選ばれ
たら良いと思いますまた話はねちょっと
それってしまったんですけれども
ここで大事なのは皆様がいろいろな僕を
創造したということです
この創造まあいわゆる先入観のようなもの
ですねこれに対して僕の答えを合わせる
ことで皆さん裏切られていったと思います
この先入観に対する裏切りっていうものが
今回多様性と密接に関係しているひとつ目
のキーワードとして先入観を挙げさせて
もらった理由です
ではなぜ先入観と多様性がこんなに密接に
関係しているのかをお話ししていきたいと
おもいます
多様性またの名をダイバーシティになって
いたりしますが関空岩が上智大学にもレイ
バーシティ推進室なるものが存在します
本当にまあ sdg ずなんて言葉ととも
に多く多く見られる多様性ダイバーシティ
という言葉ですが
いまいちピンと来ない時があります
そこで改めて気を調べてまいりました
デジタル大辞泉によると色々な種類や傾向
のものあるいは変化に富んこととありまし
た
なんとなってねーそんな気しますよね
しかしそこにただいろんなものがありまー
たようなもの傾向あるだけで対応であると
いうことであれば常に我々のいる社会や
地球はもう十分多様性が達成されている
ようにも思えますしかし現実はダイバー
シティを推進しを多様性を推進しよう
なんてところがあるぐらいですから達成さ
れているとは言いがたいと思います
今は社会では多様性ダイバーシティ
ウッド叫ばれています
しかしどうもその中で使われている多様性
という言葉は一人歩きをしておりなんだが
言葉遊びのように思えて仕方ありません
そこで今一度皆さんと多様性という言葉の
本質について考えていきたいとおもいます
ここで私の先輩のストーリーをシェアさせ
ていただきたいと思います
彼女は私が以前いた中国の大学の先輩で私
と同じ日中ハーフなんですが日本に日本人
の会さんがいらっしゃいました
やるとき中国に遊びにおいでよという先輩
の誘いを彼氏さんはなんか危なそうで
なんか来たがそうだからやるという理由で
ことあったんですね
そしてそのを横山を後から聞いた話なん
ですがなんで中国にルーツなる女の子と
付き合ってるのなんて言ってしまっていた
みたいです
実はこれ先ほどの私の問題とすごく似てい
て中国ってどんなところあるいは中国人で
どんな人という質問に対する答えがなんか
危なくてなんか汚いまよえるなんかだった
んですね
もしその彼氏さんとご家族が中国に遊びに
来てくれていれば先ほどの我々の問題と
課題のように裏切りがあったかもしれませ
んすごく簡単なことなんですが先入観を
持ってもそれを疑ったり信じすぎないと
いうことが大切なんですね
先入観を持つなあるいは専用かを持つな
悪いことだというような考え方をする人も
いますが
人間ですから知らないものあるいは不安な
ものに対して先入観を持ってしまうのは
仕方ないと思っています川柳家は持ちたく
なくても持ってしまうものそう私は考えて
います
なので自分のもっと先入観を疑ってみたり
あるいは裏切られることを少し阪神でい
たり自分の先入観とうまく付き合っていく
ことでこの他人との違いいわゆる多様性を
受け入れる助けになるんじゃないかと思っ
てこのアイディアをシェアさせていただき
ます
多様性の本質でしまうひとつ目の
アイディア
先入観とうまく付き合いです
先ほど多様性という言葉が独り歩きして
いるあるいは言葉遊びのようだと私は言い
ましたが
それに付随してと言いますかこんな疑問を
持つようになりました
なんで多様であることがすごく正しいかの
ように言われているのだろうか
先ほどようにただいろんな種類のものが
置かれているだけでは少し乱雑なような気
もしてしまいます
今度は考えて受け入れることと考えずに
ただ受け入れることの違いを考えてみたい
と思います
ご不満という社会学者の考えの中に儀礼的
無関心というものがあります
簡単にいうと例えば皆様がエレベーターの
中にいて誰かと目が合ってしまったりした
時にずっと凝視したりはしませんよね
すぐに目をそらしたり一言すいませんと
言ってから目をそらすと思います
もしくはそもそも目を合わせないより
スマホみたり
まあ各界の案内を見たりしている人が
ほとんどだと思います
最近だと思わず咳をしてしまった人がいて
もちらっと見るくらいが関の山ではない
でしょうか
この無関心の装いがたぎったの間には札を
起こさないあるいは長を取るという面に
おいて現代で必要な現象であると言えます
では多様性に今度はこれを当てはめて考え
てみましょう
私が個人的にこの先現れてくるあるいは
もう表れているかもと思っているのはこれ
はあくまで私の造語なんですが儀礼的ジュ
ヨンとでも呼べそうなものです
つまりは他者を受け入れることを予想と
いうことです
対応であることが良いとされているような
価値観が表立って目立つ中で自分の中では
納得がいかないあるいはどちらでもない
ように考えるものを受け入れるあるいは
受け入れるように装うことで多様性に富ん
でいるという姿を仮に成立させてしまう
方向に助長していくということが考えられ
ます
受け入れることを社会的に強制とまでは
言わないものの摩擦を起こさないため調和
をもたらすために受け入れるということが
今後多くなっていくのではないかという
ことです
例えばタッツーやボディーピアスをはじめ
とした新大改造悪い例かもしれません
あくまで例なので決して気分を害して
いただきたくはないのですが
タトゥーや少し過激な心配改造を見聞きし
た際自分自身では少し違和感やちょっと
怖いなどと感じたとしても
それを受け入れるあるいは受け入れようと
務めあるいは受け入れなければいけないと
考える場合がほとんどだと思います
そこには個人を尊重したり多様性を
受け入れなければいけないという道徳べき
関連や社会的通念が先立っているとみる
ことができるでしょう
それはもちろん必要なことですし必要な
場合がたくさんあると思います
しかし私がここで何を言いたいかというと
何も考えずにただ違いを受け入れるだけで
は多様性を後押しすることにはならないと
いうことです
先ほどの私が出したしょうもない問題同様
にまずはその物事だったり1対象について
考えることが大切だと私は考えます
それがすごく大事な人だったり親しい間柄
だったりすればなおのことだと思います
多様性というものは何か大きな組織や
大きな社会の中で考えられがちですが
私たちのような個人では権力者でもない
限りこの社会のシステムや機能には大きく
鑑賞できません
そこで一人一人がつながりの中で意識を
しっかり持って結果的に干渉していくと
いうことが大事だと考えています少し話が
それてしまいましたが多様であることが
正しいとされるような彼とは多様性の本質
に目を向けることなくただただ思考停止で
受け入れることを装うことでありそれは
本当に多様性日本の社会と呼べず多様性と
いう言葉遊びをしているに過ぎないと
言えるのではないでしょうか
例えば
アカデミー賞では作品に様々な人種や階層
の人々が一定数いなければいけないという
ような基準が設けられていることを知って
いる方もいらっしゃると思います
このことについては賛否両論ありますし私
の立場がどちらというわけではありません
がこのように現在では多様性を推進する
ための制度が設けられ意図的多様な社会を
推進実現していこうというような面がある
のです
多様であることをすごく大切に思っている
反面たようでなければいけないと強制断定
してしまうのは少し矛盾を孕んでいるよう
な気もしてしまいますよね
ということで2つめのアイディアは
他社の違いというものについてしっかり
考えた上で受け入れるということです
拒絶することを推奨しているわけでは
決してありませんが思考停止て違いを
受け入れることが多様性は投資する材料と
もならないでしょう
日本の多様性を取り巻く現状はどう
でしょうか
再任ですとジェンダーギャップ指数の世界
ランキングで日本がかなり低い順位だった
のは記憶に新しいかもしれません
他にも自身のことを考えていらっしゃる方
周りの大切な方を考えていらっしゃる方
いろんな方がいると思いますいろんな対応
性があると思いますその中で私が自分の
感想日本の現状を上げると青ばいいところ
をたくさんしかし課題もまだまだたくさん
といったところでしょうか
例えば日本の多機能と a は世界へ類を
見ないくらいたくさんの利用者を想定され
て作られています
反対に何回も言いますがダイバーシティ
推進室なるものができなきゃいけないけど
まだまだ推進されていないものそれが多様
性とも言えます
本日はあくまで私の個人的な角度から
多様性の本質に迫るためのアイデアを2つ
ご紹介させていただきました
皆さんまだ覚えてらっしゃいますでしょう
か
一つ目
先入観とうまく付き合う
そして2つ目
思考停止で受け入れるな
性処言い方は乱暴かもしれませんがそれ
ぐらいの気概気持ちがあるということでご
容赦ください
アメリカではその人種の多様性を示すため
に人種のるつぼという言葉がありそれが
だんだんと人種のサラダボウルという言葉
に変わっていきました
るつぼとはその中に金属を入れて溶かして
一つにする集まりその人衆を一つにする
みたいな意味が込められていて
サラダボウルにはサラダ野菜のそれぞれの
個性を失わずにサラダとしての調和がとれ
た個性も死なずに調和がとれたそんな状態
を指し示します
これは本当にただの言葉遊びになって
しまうんですがしかしこのサラダという
言葉は意外と多様性の本質を突いているの
ではないのかなと個人的には考えています
まあ今のところですが
ただは野菜の寄せ集めではなくきちんとお
互いを分かり合ってサラダの中で調和が
取れているこれが多様性の本質とでも
言えるんじゃないでしょうか
私は本日今日冒頭デー
皆さんの顔を見えないことが不幸中の幸い
だなどとのたまっておりましたが
最後ここまできて皆さんのリアクション
表情が見れないことが少し残念であり
寂しく思っております
今日この場が皆さんが少しでも多様性に
ついて考えるあるいは関心を持つきっかけ
となってくだされば非常に嬉しいです
本日はどうもご静聴ありがとうございまし
た